i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
[Música]
como seres humanos sentimos muchas
emociones tristezas decepciones amor y
disfrutamos la amistad
y también tenemos en nuestra naturaleza
comunicarnos lo que sentimos a otras
personas
nunca le contaron nada a nadie en
confidencia por ejemplo de quién están
enamorados qué opinión tiene de algún
tema controversial y después le dicen no
le cuentes a nadie por favor si se
quedan un poco un poco inquietos de que
lo que contaron tal vez se pueda
divulgar de una forma
accidental accidentalmente o
intencionalmente lo que le estoy estaban
haciendo indirectamente era pidiéndole a
esa persona que preserven su privacidad
y privacidad que es privacidad si buscan
en el diccionario van a encontrar algo
como privacidad es el ámbito de la vida
privada que uno tiene el derecho de
proteger de intromisiones ajenas
una definición bastante ilustrativa pero
no dice mucho proteger como
de quien a mi me gusta ver la privacidad
como un tema de control control de que
el control de como la información
relacionada con uno se divulga si
ustedes tienen control de como su
información se divulga ustedes tienen
privacidad
por eso cuando le cuentan a un amigo ya
no tienen el control exclusivo de como
la información correspondiente a ustedes
se puede divulgar y quién de nosotros no
tiene un amigo o amiga que habla además
siempre no
hoy tenemos a alguien aquí le contamos
muchas intimidades
que le contamos todo lo que pensamos o
casi todo lo que pensamos ideas
políticas sentimientos aspectos la vida
cotidiana pueden adivinar a quién
los teléfonos móviles
y para que no me crean les propongo el
siguiente ejercicio ubiquen en el
público alguien que no conozca que esté
sentado 12 sillas lejanos de ustedes
sacan su teléfono de bloqueen lo y pasen
solo
no se sienten incómodos
y como no se van a sentir incómodos si
esa persona después de leer su teléfono
va a tener acceso a muchas de sus
informaciones privadas y la puede
divulgar y usted no pueden controlarlo
no confían en esa persona que es de san
nicolás
pero si confían en las aplicaciones que
tenemos acá
como saben que las aplicaciones de acá
no hablan de más
pero sería injusto tener toda la
atención en los teléfonos celulares o
vivimos en un mundo altamente conectado
donde es más y más común que en muchos
dispositivos monitor y en nuestras
actividades y lo que hacemos
y por más honesto que sean esos
dispositivos que generalmente proveen un
servicio
se podrían usar para aprender aspectos
de su vida privada aunque ustedes no
hayan dicho ni una sola palabra
para entender esto un poquito mejor
déjenme ejemplificar lo
hoy en día los edificios se vuelven son
inteligentes
generalmente tienen sensores de
ocupación en cada habitación saben si
hay alguien en la habitación o no para
poder hacer un uso más eficiente de
el aire acondicionado la calefacción el
purificador de aire ahora si nos
focalizamos en una habitación y nosotros
como proveedor de ese servicio podemos
ver que en la habitación cada 25 minutos
se desocupa
y se ocupa de nuevo después de tres
minutos hay una alta chance que la
persona que está en esa habitación es
fumadora
porque ese es el patrón de los fumadores
ahora si esa persona ciertos días sale
en ciertas horas rutinariamente de la
habitación durante unos minutos hay una
alta probabilidad que sepa qué religión
tiene
esa persona no dijo nada de su vida
privada y ya perdió el control
y decir qué religión tiene y si fumo no
estas son las dos formas que uno tiene
vendida de perder privacidad hablando
explícitamente o revelando exponiéndola
mediante sus hábitos
pero esta forma de perder privacidad
son conocidas en el mundo literario
desde siempre que el género literario
las novelas criminales
mi mujer cariño le encantan las novelas
de criminales y aprendí
que es muy raro que no es novela
criminal el criminal confiese sino la
novela se termina
rapidísimo si todo el esfuerzo del
detective está puesto en extraer
información de los sospechosos mediante
sus actividades mediante las cosas que
no dicen estuvo en la habitación durante
el crimen no estuvo en la habitación
durante que me estaba viajando transpira
cuando lo interrogan etcétera etcétera y
una novela criminal solamente afecta a
una docena de personas
si volvemos de vuelta al mundo
tecnológico
la tecnología que tenemos hoy en día
expande significativamente las
posibilidades de perder nuestra
privacidad vamos a seguir contando las
cosas en nuestros teléfonos en nuestras
tablets y va a haber más dispositivos en
el futuro y también más y más servicios
nos van a monitorear y es como tener un
detective en tu hombro todo el tiempo
con la diferencia que no estamos en una
novela criminal
estamos en nuestra vida cotidiana
quién tiene un detective en tu vida en
su vida cotidiana yo no
qué es tan cierto es que podamos tener
privacidad en un mundo altamente
conectado y con mucha tecnología
yo soy profesor e investigador y hemos
desarrollado tecnología para ayudar a
crear sistemas que manejen la
información de los usuarios y mantengan
su privacidad
tengo un grupo de cuatro estudiantes
brillantes trabajando en esto en la
universidad de yale merz en gotemburgo
en suecia
tuvimos la suerte de publicar artículos
en las conferencias más prestigiosas a
nivel mundial sobre dicha temática e
interactuar con las personas más
provenientes en el campo a nivel mundial
también les tengo una buena y una mala
noticia
empecemos por la mala
crear sistemas que garanticen la
privacidad es difícil es un tema no
resuelto para ejemplificar este punto
piensen en los sistemas de seguridad que
tienen en sus teléfonos último modelo
son del estilo
la aplicación de red x necesita acceso a
sus fotos contactos localización
etcétera etcétera para poder funcionar y
usted están en la disyuntiva
le doy permiso o no la uso
desafortunadamente los sistemas de
seguridad que dan acceso o no a
información no son suficientes para
garantizar privacidad privacidad es como
se divulga
qué saben ustedes cuando le dan permiso
a una aplicación a todos sus datos como
los divulga hoy en día solamente
confiamos en las aplicaciones como
confiamos a ese amigo o amiga de que no
hable de más
por qué
ahora las buenas noticias
hay dos tecnologías que son muy
prometedoras para resolver el problema
de cómo se pierde privacidad usualmente
y me gustaría contarles sobre ellas
la primera se llama el control de flujo
de información
y es una tecnología que fue originada en
los 70 en los ambientes militares para
evitar que documentos super secretos se
revelen al público pero la tecnología
avanzó
y se puede se adaptó y se puede usar
para navegadores el internet de las
cosas etcétera etcétera y cómo funciona
lo que hace hace un seguimiento dentro
del sistema informático de cómo la
información privada y cualquier dato
derivado de ellos
se propaga en el sistema y cuando el
sistema trata hablar de más levantó una
bandera y te dice no no esto no se puede
hacer
veamos un ejemplo acá tenemos un chat
entre dos personas personas que tienen
mensajes audios y fotos y personas que
tiene un mensaje o algún mensaje de voz
perdón y un mensaje
esa conversación tendría que estar
restringida a la privacidad de a&b
en el caso que
decidiera enviar un mensaje de a algún
otro grupo o alguna otra persona
el sistema de control de flujo de
información lo va a detener porque hace
un seguimiento de cómo la información
privada de aire se propaga y va a decir
esto no es posible a menos que a lo
aprueben
similarmente si ve saco un screenshot de
la conversación es screen yo no podría
ser compartido con nadie a menos que lo
apruebe que se pueda hacer así
piensen conocen alguna aplicación de
mensajería que funciona así
implementar sistemas de control del
flujo información no es fácil requiere
romper con las formas tradicionales de
crear sistemas y además para que sea
efectivo necesita que varios componentes
de el sistema contribuye al seguimiento
de la propagación de los datos privados
la segunda tecnología que les quiero
contar hoy un poco más nueva del año
2006 se llama privacidad diferencial y
lo que hace es privacidad diferencial te
permite hacer un análisis en esos datos
que provienen de las actividades de los
usuarios como la del edificio cada vez
que uno dentro salía de la habitación
esos son todos datos que provienen de la
actividad de los individuos
y privacidad diferencial me va a
permitir hacer ciertos análisis sobre
esos datos de una forma que pueda
garantizar la privacidad de los
involucrados volvamos al ejemplo de los
fumadores acá tenemos una gráfica
generada por esta tecnología de los
fumadores en los diferentes pisos piso 1
2 3 y 4 como vemos el piso 2 está lleno
de fumadores más que el resto
y la esta tecnología lo que hace
agrega pequeñas variaciones aleatorias a
los resultados del estudio que son que
sé qué significa eso
cuenta la cantidad de fumadores en el
primer piso inundado y depende lo que
caiga agregados acá algunos cuentan la
cantidad de fumadores en el segundo piso
tirón dado y depende lo que caiga agregó
saca y así sucesivamente y usted lo que
ven acá es el resultado que ya tiene
estas pequeñas agregaciones o
sustracciones de fumadores
y así es como protege la privacidad y
demostrarle por qué porque funciona
focalicemos en el piso número 2 que
dónde están la mayoría de los fumadores
imagínense que todo eso es el sol es
persona el piso 2 algunos fumas otros no
llegamos el mismo experimento con
privacidad diferencial pero saquemos una
persona cualquiera
si corremos el experimento de nuevo creo
que presten atención en la columna 2 el
resultado podría ser que se incremente
un poquito porque aleatoriamente después
que tiene al lado agregué fumadores pero
como es aleatorio pues que cuando tiene
el lado de nuevo
y hago el mismo experimento como antes
lo saqué lo hago de nuevo operar el dado
cayó para otro lado y la barra baja
les pregunto es aquella que es aquella
que
el fumador o no
es difícil de saber así es como la
privacidad diferencial protege la
privacidad de los usuarios que
participan del estudio
pero dando con cierta exactitud
una noción de cuántos formadores tengo
por piso
son dos tecnologías que a mí me
entusiasman mucho son el foco de mi
investigación de las cosas que yo hago
todavía falta hacer desarrollo pero yo
creo que vamos por buen camino
privacidad
es necesaria para tener libertad de
expresión
uno no podría hablar con sus seres
queridos expresarse tranquilamente con
sus más honestos sentimientos si supiera
que esas conversaciones son monitoreadas
por el gobierno o puede aparecer en
algún periódico el día siguiente
más aún
privacidad diferencial los gobiernos
podrían saber cómo sus ciudadanos
piensan en temas muy controversiales
y actuar en consecuencia por ejemplo si
yo soy el gobierno ustedes son
argentinas a mí me gustaría saber las
barritas de quién está a favor de la
legalización del aborto y quién no lo
está y yo podría preguntar levanten la
mano al que está a favor de la
realización del aborto
algunos por ahí la van a levantar muchos
por ahí no
porque tal vez están a favor pero tienen
miedo de que los juzguen
los estigmatizan que los pongas de un
lado o del otro de la grieta
con privacidad diferencial uno podría
tener esas barritas protegiendo la
privacidad de lo que ustedes piensan
tenemos que luchar por poder decirle a
los sistemas informáticos estos son mis
datos privados y después tener la
garantía de que esa privacidad se va a
respetar
para hacer esto así en un futuro
la verdad que no lo sé
pero desde mi humilde posición pueden
hacer todo lo posible para seguir
contribuyendo con la ciencia que pueda
hacer que esto sea una realidad en un
futuro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]